So a word is just something that has meaning that speakers
of a language will understand. We could define words as just
what's in the dictionary, and then there would be a clear
answer for that. But certainly there are lots of things that
are words that aren't in the dictionary. And the important thing
about words is that we have rules for making new words.
For example we have a rule that says if we have
a word, we can make a new word by adding counter in
front of the old word.
I'm using the same notation that we used back in unit
one. This is a BNF replacement grammar. If you need a refresher
on this, please go back to the video that introduced that
in unit one. But the basic property is that we can replace
what's on the left side with what's on the right side.
So, anytime we have a word, we can replace it with counter-word.
And the meaning of the new word is something that goes
against the original word. So, if we started with the word, intelligence,
and I mean this in the sense of spy
craft. Not in terms of smarts. Well then, we can
use the rule. We can make the word, counter-intelligence. Intelligence
was a word. We added counter in front of it
to make counter-intelligence. And that means trying to thwart
intelligence from the enemy. We can use the rule again,
so now this is a word, and we can replace
this word with counter in front of that word, and
we get counter-counter-intelligence. And that would be trying
to thwart the enemy's counter intelligence, that's preventing you
from getting intelligence. And we could keep doing
that. We could have counter-counter-counter-intelligence. And so forth, and
these are words that, once we get up
to at least three counters, it's not something that's
used before. But it's still something that has
a sensible meaning, and we could do this for
other words. So we saw that one of the very long words was this
hippopotomonstrosesquippedaliophobia.
And if you knew that this word meant fear of long words. Even if you've never
seen the words counter in front of that before. So now we can make the new word
counter-hippopotomonstrosesquippedaliophobia.
Quite a mouthful. But even though you've never seen
that word before. And I expect most of you
have never seen that word before. Well, you could
guess that this is something that goes against the fear
of long words. Maybe, there's some new medication that
cures people of this phobia. And you could also figure
out, well, if there was a counter-counter-hippo and so
forth phobia. Well that would be something that counteracts the
counter-hippo, and that might be something where this
new drug doesn't work if you have too much
coffee. Then coffee would be a counter-counter-hippo so
forth phobia. So the point is, because English has
this rule that allows us to make new
words from old words. There's no such thing as
the longest word, we can always make a
longer word, starting from any word that we have.
If you remember how BNF grammars work, then
you should be able to answer the next quiz.